We're going to talk today about
managing technological dangers.
And in this case history on a nuclear
weapons is really a good one because it,
it,
uh,
provides insight into a whole array of
technological hazards and dangers that,
that,
uh,
we'll pick up in,
in different cases as we
move through the term.
Uh,
this one is,
is quite distinctive and it'll give
us a chance to explore a number of
questions,
uh,
in this lecture,
particularly about different
strategies like how you might,
how you might decide to,
to manage dangers in,
in different ways.
One typical approach are that was used
in this history was the reliance on
expertise.
Uh,
so technical experts,
uh,
had the responsibility not just to,
to,
uh,
design,
the new weapons,
uh,
to think about,
the other kind of public
interest applications,
especially nuclear energy in the 1950s.
Uh,
but,
but also to worry about,
uh,
what,
what would happen to the,
the bombs and the material
once it was exploded.
So the idea that you would concentrate
expertise in an organization such as the
Atomic Energy Commission at the same time,
that you would give them complete
authority over the technology.
So that a,
the statute that was passed
in 1946 the created the AEC,
I was really remarkable in that
that had concentrated authority,
it concentrated knowledge.
It gave the AEC,
uh,
the intellectual property rights so
that no corporation was allowed to
understand or work on the technology
unless they had reached a,
received a specific security clearances.
So this overlap of unlimited resources,
unlimited expertise,
and complete authority
is really remarkable.
I can't imagine a concentration
of more power in a,
in one organization.
Another critical approach to a managing
technological hazards is the control of
experimentation.
So how would you try it out?
And there are many products
in the marketplace,
many chemicals,
uh,
many other kinds of technologies
for a burning fuels,
coal,
uh,
gasoline that are released in the
markets without adequate testing.
So here's one,
uh,
that was released at grand scale and the
public really had no understanding of,
of what the government was doing
because of the classified nature of,
of the,
uh,
of the projects.
Uh,
so,
uh,
they amassed expertise in the form of
academic experts to try to figure out not
only what the destructive power of
the different weapons would be a,
but also what happened to them.
Public Education is another approach.
Uh,
and we'll see in a film
clip in a few moments.
Uh,
if our audio and video work correctly,
we'll see the atomic energy commission,
public service announcements,
uh,
designed to and,
and,
uh,
and build public support.
So,
uh,
obviously the,
the public was well aware that that,
uh,
these nuclear explosions were going on.
I mean,
walking to the top of casinos
and hotels in Las Vegas,
uh,
at night to watch them explode.
I mean,
the public was well aware of this,
uh,
but they understood well
the destructive power,
uh,
but they didn't really
know what to make of,
of,
uh,
what the danger might be.
The danger to,
uh,
the environment.
The,
the danger to,
to human health of,
of the remnants of the explosions.
Uh,
another approach would be to
limit the potency of a technology.
So to try it on a really small scale.
And what's curious about this was that
the arms race that grew between the
Soviets and the US s,
uh,
caused the development,
the rapid development
of bigger and bigger,
uh,
weapons greater and
greater explosive power.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
rather than,
trying to move from a system,
uh,
which we'll see in a couple of weeks,
with pesticides or pharmaceuticals is
another good example where the attempt,
uh,
on the,
on the part of corporations
is to ever more design,
uh,
technologies or,
or drugs or,
or biocides that,
that pose less and less risk,
but are still effective
in getting the job done,
minimize environmental
release and exposure.
Uh,
the,
the increased potency moving from the,
uh,
first atom bombs to the
hydrogen bombs in the mid 1950s,
uh,
was the opposite direction.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
more and more materials were
being released to the atmosphere,
uh,
as testing expanded.
Uh,
another notion that grew
in this history was the,
the idea of susceptibility,
special vulnerability that different
people would be exposed to these chemicals
in different ways because of their
behavior or because of their specific
physiology.
Uh,
so that,
you know,
chemicals move differently
in children or in,
uh,
fetuses and they do and,
and you or,
or in me,
so that,
uh,
basic,
patterns of growth and development,
uh,
determine this and also
compensating those that are harmed.
Uh,
so that with vaccines,
h one n one vaccine is
a good example of that.
Uh,
vaccines always affect
some people adversely.
Uh,
and if people are seriously damaged,
if their health loss is substantial,
uh,
we have laws that are in
place to offer compensation.
Uh,
if the adverse effect can be
tied tightly to the exposure.
So that,
uh,
we'll,
we'll look in a few moments here or
closer to the end of the lecture at
different compensation strategies,
recognizing that there would be people
that would be intensely exposed,
particularly those that were involved in,
in,
uh,
producing the technology or in other
occupations that led them to experience
greater risk.
So the atomic energy act of 1946
really created this authority.
It's a remarkable piece of legislation.
And uh,
there,
there are very few other pieces
of law that I can point to,
uh,
that,
would,
would give such power to an organization.
So it created a five member
atomic energy commission,
uh,
that,
was assigned the responsibility
to manage the technology.
And this gradually evolved
into the Department of Energy,
which we have today.
So I'm going to try to show you
a couple of film clips here.
Hopefully this will,
uh,
pick up on the effects
of radiation and fallout.
So let the capsule can be retrieved.
But after exposure and the radiation,
the Ledger Dev organization may do its
damage or there to your work or cool one
that may physically I'm directly destroy
tissue or eventually they call it all
the top guy to cut those
which concern us principally.
They have life period ranging from
several years who follows the beers.
No harm unless they are taking into our
body with food or drinking water or in
the air we breathe.
Let us consider the results of a
powerful thermonuclear explosion and the
Pacific proving grounds in the Marshall
Islands 11 degrees north of the equator.
That huge cloud source up punches through
the Tropo pause and find any spreads
and stabilizes as high as 70 or 80,000
feet entirely within the stratosphere.
Late.
Yeah.
This brings us to the most.
Why didn't they discuss
sufficient product?
Strong Cim,
90 chemically similar to the soil,
calcium with which it becomes mixed.
The start you have 90 follows calcium
through its regular cycled into our
platform and into the bowl.
Meat and milk of our plant,
getting hammered,
reading our own bodies.
This function I like.
Calcium tends to be
concentrated in our phone,
particularly those of children
who are building new bone.
You're ready.
Hey,
from the structure of the night,
he has extremely short range in the body
so it causes no genetic breadth to the
reproductive cells,
the bone marrow,
and in the form of either leukemia or bone
Fisher that it would be a
tragic thing for those injured.
No matter how small or number,
whether it be physically,
very few categories can be justified.
Your personal value outside
of the scope of this report,
each citizen must make heads or her own.
You will maintain that
there is no actual prep.
It's a free world at all.
Certainly not.
That could justify either testing,
nuclear armament,
the officer's viewpoint.
Hold that Paul,
that's been absolutely necessary for
protection against common responsibility
and a threat and this
view all off category.
When we see it
and the service you can mind
in a war,
which is not,
I know John of your Paul,
you're kind of promoter stars.
What's remarkable about his comments
was he demonstrated by the late 1950s at
the AEC had really strong knowledge of
not just what the effects of the bombs
might be,
but also what the health
implications might be.
So they'd worked out the science,
they worked out the science actually in,
in a more sophisticated way than we
have for the majority of chemicals that
we've classified as toxic or
hazardous under the clean air act,
the safe drinking water act,
the toxic substance control act today.
So it's really pretty remarkable that,
uh,
this concentration of expertise
and authority and resources,
uh,
produced a quality of knowledge that a
is really pretty unusual in 20th century
environmental history.
Now,
the,
uh,
experts wondered where
they should experiment,
should they experiment
in the United States?
Should they experiment in
other parts of the world?
And they decided that they
would concentrate most of their,
they're a hydrogen bomb explosions in
the Pacific in the Marshall Islands.
And one of the atolls in the
Pacific is Bikini Island,
uh,
which is a very small area.
And I'm going to spend a few
moments talking about this.
These atolls basically are,
are volcanic,
uh,
so that the rim of the volcano was
sitting on the surface of the ocean.
Uh,
and what you see here is
really a rim of coral and sand.
And several hundred Bikinians were asked
by the federal government back in 1945
if they would move from the island,
if they would give up their
homeland in order to provide a,
a location or a territory
for the explosions,
recognizing that the Marshall Islands are,
are a hundred,
excuse me,
thousands of square miles
of open ocean with a very,
very small population.
There.
There are very few places on
earth where you could find such a,
uh,
an area where the population
population density was so low.
Again,
they were worried about,
uh,
not really understanding
what would happen to the,
the materials,
uh,
and what the exposures might be.
So the idea was to move the islanders
away from the center of the low or the
explosions to save for islands.
So eventually the Bikinians
decided that they would,
uh,
move from the homeland,
to surrounding islands and the government
first place them on an island known as
Ron [inaudible],
Ron Zurich,
uh,
was not as fertile.
Uh,
you can't see this very carefully,
but,
uh,
if you go on Google Earth,
you'll see the,
the,
uh,
amount of,
the,
uh,
a land that is covered by
vegetation is extremely small,
so that they tried to grow crops here
and they found that the soils were very
infertile.
Basically,
they were just sand and beneath
the sand was volcanic material,
uh,
so very nutrient poor soils and
that really would not support them.
And,
uh,
they planted coconut trees,
but the coconut trees were,
were killed by,
by a fires.
They were then moved to quash Milan,
uh,
within about six months.
And Kwajalein is a,
another atole,
uh,
basically a,
a ring of,
of coral reefs.
Uh,
but it's also a military base.
And they were forced into a,
uh,
a,
a tent encampment for,
for a period of about
three or four months.
And they protested that they had
no place to grow their own food,
that they had no fishing boats and they
couldn't maintain the lifestyle that
they had had before.
Gradually,
they were moved,
uh,
within actually about 12 months,
they were moved to the island of Kiwi,
a Kiwi.
Uh,
I could not find any,
any photograph of Kiwi,
uh,
but,
Keely was,
uh,
an island that was not our,
is an island that w is not,
uh,
a on a toll a instead it,
it has no lagoon,
uh,
and it's open.
Uh,
it's,
it faces the open ocean on all sides,
uh,
which meant that they
had no lagoon deficient,
uh,
so that they had a very poor land,
again,
land that a w would not support
the development of crops.
And gradually over a period of,
uh,
several years,
the population began to starve.
The military eventually brought them a
fishing boats that were large enough so
that they could continue their,
their fishing activities.
Uh,
but they lived a miserable life
through the 1950s and early 1960s.
Uh,
what was going on on Bikini in their
absence was a series of experiments and a
one was quite curious.
It,
uh,
I was one of the first attempts to blow
up a weapons both above ground and below
the ocean,
and they decided to test the
resilience of the naval fleet,
uh,
two different,
to different intensities of,
of what other,
of different sizes of the weapons.
So they amassed this group of ships
that you can see in the upper right,
uh,
and within the center of it,
a,
they detonated a bomb,
uh,
wondering what would happen to the
navy if the Soviets dropped a bomb,
say at Pearl Harbor or a if they
found a fleet of US ships at sea.
Hello.
Yeah.
Remarkably,
the atomic energy commission,
also a hired film crews and
outfit them and led suits,
uh,
so that they would fly in the vicinity,
that those films were taken by,
by,
uh,
a cruise that we're sitting inside
aircraft that were flying around the,
uh,
the mushroom cloud.
But they also flew directly
into the mushroom cloud.
And before they had a,
offered them the possibility of,
of,
uh,
the,
the lead suits to offer
protection from the radiation.
Uh,
the,
uh,
the pilots and the crews came back and
they experienced such a high level of
radiation that the,
uh,
the expert's became quite worried
about their long term health.
I saw the gradually,
the,
uh,
the shielding grew as
they flew in and around.
So a single aircraft,
for example,
would be outfitted with up to 70 different
cameras so they could figure out what
the pattern of radiation emission was.
Uh,
and,
uh,
what the,
the,
uh,
effect would be as the
cloud would dissipate,
uh,
in the direction of the prevailing winds.
Now,
among the 23 different bombs
that were dropped on this island,
uh,
Bravo in 1954 was perhaps
one of the most remarkable,
the first hydrogen bomb that
had been developed in the world,
uh,
that had,
an explosive force a nearly a
thousand times that a force,
uh,
the bomb that was dropped
on Hiroshima so that the,
they,
they really did not understand
what the effect might be.
Uh,
what the,
the,
the distance,
uh,
of damage would be away from ground zero.
So this was called a the big one.
And by the way,
these clips are coming from a,
a,
a film that I'll put on reserve if you'd
like to see the entire film called the
atomic bomb movie.
Call me,
get him his food.
At 1954 castle largest
device ever testing students,
Robin was the hydrogen ball using some
of the thermal nuclear fuel confirming
the designs of Edward Teller and Stan
paving the way to producing aircraft
deliverable.
How did these bombs and more effective,
those
minutes
float
release launch one of these?
Yeah.
Yes sir.
So it's a prize.
The president is surprise the experts.
It created destruction over,
uh,
an area that was completely unexpected
when they finally interpreted the
radiation readings from ships and
different monitoring facilities that they
established.
They produced this map.
And this is a contour map in a way,
uh,
in a contour map that the,
different,
uh,
ellipses a would represent
different elevations.
Uh,
so think about this as
representing different
intensities of radiation that one
would experience had they been in,
in a proximity to the
site of the explosion.
First of all,
uh,
the explosion itself created a,
a crater in the atoll.
It was a mile and a half wide,
uh,
in one direction and a mile
wide in another direction.
Uh,
but this graph or chart
was more disturbing,
uh,
especially to those that
had security clearances.
And we're responsible for funding,
uh,
in the Senate in the house because it
demonstrated that the lethal zone is
represented by the area
that's crosshatched.
This area spans a distance of about 170
miles in length by about 70 miles in
width.
So if this were a perfect
circle and it landed on,
say,
a downtown in the mall in Washington DC,
it would would've wiped out all of
the buildings within a 12 mile radius.
Within a matter of several years.
The Russians,
uh,
developed a bomb that they first
found was too big in order to,
to lift off the ground.
And eventually they worried that a,
the aircraft that would,
would release it wouldn't be able to get
far enough away so that it wouldn't be
destroyed.
Uh,
and gradually they overcame
those technical difficulties.
And a Tsar Bomba was the largest bomb
ever exploded in northern Russia,
uh,
in the 20th century.
Uh,
and it had a destructive force that,
uh,
was lethal,
over a distance of some 500 miles.
A 1500 square miles would
be completely devastated.
So the bikini explosion would have
taken an area from New Jersey,
uh,
to the other side of
Boston and leveled it.
Uh,
and an area that roughly would have gone
from just south of Albany down to long
island sound,
uh,
would have destroyed all structures.
It would have made the area uninhabitable.
Uh,
it would have radiated the soil
so that no crops could grow.
Uh,
any,
any other vegetation that Mike Rowe
would have absorbed the radionuclides.
So the,
uh,
the trees could not be
used for building material.
They couldn't be used for firewood
because it would simply release the
radioactivity back into
the atmosphere we're in,
into the environment.
This understanding of the
enormous destructive force
of a single weapon really
transformed the impression of the experts
about the implications of what they
were doing.
And they were extremely worried that
the public would understand the scale of
the damage that,
that,
uh,
the single weapon could face.
By the way,
how many nuclear weapons?
Uh,
we're in existence by the
late 1980s and early 1990s,
roughly 70,000,
70,000.
That ranged from bombs with this scale
to those that would be deliverable,
uh,
via a suitcase or a
from an artillery shell.
So an enormous diversity of weapons,
an enormous,
uh,
destructive capacity
that was being a math,
it was simply being built up in
the stockpiles around the world.
So what was,
uh,
the result of this understanding?
Uh,
more classification of information,
more secrecy,
uh,
more worry about how to tell a story,
to develop a narrative advantage,
uh,
to,
to be able to persuade the public
that continued testing was important.
And,
uh,
that,
in order to,
to,
uh,
prevent the Soviets from believing that,
that,
uh,
they could survive a first strike,
that,
uh,
we would build more weapons and,
and bigger weapons.
Now what about the island itself?
What about the environmental
implications of 23 different tests on a,
on a,
on,
uh,
south Pacific or a Pacific,
a toll such as this?
Well,
you saw what happened
to the coconut trees.
All of the,
all of the frauds were blown off at all.
The coconuts were blown
off at all the bark,
the exterior bark,
uh,
was burned off of it.
Well,
the government decided that,
well,
we'll just,
uh,
we'll just go back and we'll,
we'll cut all those trees,
uh,
and we'll,
we'll plant new ones.
So they planted 50,000 new
coconut trees on the island.
Uh,
they then said,
well,
you know,
we know that the soils are,
are,
uh,
still highly radioactive.
Uh,
we'll,
we'll go in and we'll scrape all those
soils off and we'll bring in soil from
other islands so that they will
have the potential once again to,
to grow new crops.
So they're thinking about,
well,
uh,
in the,
in the film clip you saw a few minutes
ago now you saw the atomic energy
commission officials saying that they
understood what the key roots of exposure
might be and those were by air,
uh,
via food,
and via drinking water
or by dermal uptake,
uh,
through the skin.
Now,
those are the four routes of exposure,
uh,
that we would think about today
if we were wondering about the,
the,
uh,
risk or the hazards of any technology.
What's the root of exposure?
Is it by air?
Is it by food?
Is it by,
uh,
inhalation?
Is it by dermal uptake?
A,
these are all ways that a,
that chemicals can get in your body.
So understanding their
persistence in vegetation,
there a pattern of accumulation
and different kinds of foods.
Uh,
did the compounds make their
way into drinking water?
Uh,
and what would it be?
There will be their persistence.
What would be their ecological pathways?
How would they move
through the environment?
Uh,
and what,
what would the long term threat?
Uh,
B.
So here's a unexampled,
uh,
after planning 50,000 coconut trees,
they found no hint that there would
be a problem with the coconuts,
the vegetables,
and the water.
This was his late as early 1978.
So they faced this problem.
How do we persuade the public that
this dangerous technology was worth
developing?
Uh,
that it,
uh,
it made sense to continue the
funding and continue the testing,
uh,
based on the argument that we have to
understand how we might be able to survive
a nuclear attack.
Uh,
but also that the Russians
need to understand,
uh,
that,
they could not possibly
initiate a nuclear attack,
uh,
without committing suicide.
So they developed a variety of
different public service announcements.
I'm going to show you one of those
now that's entitled Common Sense.
This is a u s air force film.
Uh,
and this is Marilyn Monroe who was,
you probably know a film star at that,
during that period of time.
So message there was the
technology is manageable.
Use common sense,
uh,
avoid exposure.
And what would this mean?
What would this mean to,
uh,
to,
hundreds of millions of people
in the United States at the time,
or to the government's responsibility
to educate them so that they would know
what to do?
Well,
you tsar and,
uh,
the Bravo test,
basically told them that the
cities were enormously vulnerable.
So what happened during
the Eisenhower era?
One of the,
the,
uh,
first thing that was done,
following this was the investment of tens
of billions of dollars in the national
highway program.
So the argument was,
well,
we really need to be able to
move troops around the city,
but they were really concerned about
developing the capacity to evacuate.
Uh,
is there,
is there the possibility that we could,
uh,
protect against dangerous exposures,
which are most of concern,
uh,
their,
highest,
uh,
in closest proximity in
space and time to the,
uh,
the side of the blast.
So if we could warn people,
uh,
via sirens,
by a radio announcements,
if we could tell people what they need
to do in the event that we detected an
attack,
that would help them.
Uh,
so not only did they,
uh,
they build a hundreds of thousands of
miles of highways in the United States and
the hope that evacuations might work,
uh,
but they also developed evacuation drills.
And I don't have a shot of duck and cover,
but to ask your parents
about duck and cover a,
they'd probably remember being told that,
uh,
an emergency drill was going
to be held in the school.
All the children are now required to get
down on their hands and knees and duck
underneath their desks
and cover their head.
And in fact,
there's a cute little song that I,
uh,
almost developed the courage to sing
to you called the duck and cover,
but I'm going to resist doing that.
The idea that a ducking and covering
beneath your school dusk would offer you,
uh,
sufficient protection against exposure,
and the damage of a
collapsing buildings is,
uh,
quite,
quite ridiculous.
But it was part of their approach.
It was part of their
persuasive strategy to,
to convince the public that
they could take precautions,
they could get themselves into the subway,
or they could build the,
uh,
the fallout shelters and store it with
food and water and offer themselves
protection until the bulk of the
radiation had had blown away.
Well,
you know,
we've had quite a bit of experience
with evacuation drills and,
uh,
a couple,
that you,
you may,
uh,
recall would include a hurricane Katrina
Hurricane Katrina found people sitting
on the highway stalled trying to leave,
leave,
uh,
southern Louisiana and
a parts of Texas and,
and also other parts of the Gulf coast,
uh,
so that,
moving people out of a city,
even despite having an
interstate highway system,
was much,
much more difficult than
anyone could possibly imagine.
And,
uh,
these are a bit out of order,
but I wanted to come
back and show you this.
A notice.
Back in 2005,
the Connecticut State police
ordered an evacuation of the state.
Uh,
there was no stated purpose,
uh,
but this aired on the radio
and it was out on the Internet.
Uh,
an evacuation of the
cities was called for a,
and it was an error.
It was an electronic signal
that had been tripped.
Uh,
and what was the public's response to
the evacuation request and the warning?
Nothing.
They didn't even receive one phone call,
a so that the public is quite
actually resistant to a rings of,
of the alarm.
So although the Bikinians were promised
that only one or two tests would be
conducted on their island back in 1945,
uh,
more nuclear energy was released on
this one site than at any other site in,
in history.
Uh,
so that the cumulative
force of bombs had exploded.
There was nearly four times the energy
released over almost a thousand tests
conducted at the Nevada test site.
Uh,
so this was,
uh,
labeled the most contaminated
site in the world.
And at the same time,
President Johnson was feeling great
pressure to clean up the island and uh,
to,
uh,
basically remove the
radioactive sands and soils,
uh,
to,
restore the vegetation to,
uh,
try to figure out whether or
not a fisheries might be viable,
uh,
so that the population
could return to the island.
So one decade after the bombing ceased,
uh,
President Johnson gave the okay for the
Bikinians to return to their homeland.
Now,
during the next decade,
uh,
scientists continued to work,
particularly at the Brookhaven
national laboratory on Long Island,
uh,
and reported back to the House and Senate.
And here's an example that
the house appropriations
committee heard reports from
these scientists in 1973 that the CCM
[inaudible] concentrations were 10 times
higher than the 1970 levels.
CCM is measured in their urine.
It's an easy,
an easy radio,
new quad to detect.
And it was attributed to the foods
that were grown on the island.
So during the period when
they were restoring the soils
and they were trying to,
to figure out which crops they could grow,
there were often importing food,
but as they grew more and
more food on the island,
they found that the,
the plants that they had had chosen,
we're drawing the radionuclides from the
soils and from the underground waters.
So they decided,
oh,
well,
perhaps our surveillance,
uh,
was not sufficient enough.
Our sampling strategy didn't pick up the
fact that the underlying aquifers were
contaminated or that the soil
concentrations were higher than were,
were originally estimated.
And they found that,
uh,
they had scraped the top soil off,
but they've not gone deeply enough.
And that some of the plants were
drawing water up from a distance that,
that,
uh,
included,
sands and,
and,
uh,
organic matter that had absorbed
significant concentrations.
So that by 1978,
uh,
the body burdens succeeded
the maximum permissible level,
uh,
according to,
the,
the National Institute of Health,
they took the islanders off the island
again and they were returned to the
island of Keely,
the one that,
uh,
has no,
coral reefs surrounding that,
that there was open to open to pounding,
pounding,
surf.
So they were allowed to stay there for,
for a,
a year.
There were conflicting interpretations
of the evidence that was available.
And you find,
we'll find this again and again through
the 20th century with respect to air
quality,
uh,
arguments over how much,
inhalation of an air pollutant is okay.
Or how much of a drinking
water contaminant is okay,
or how much of a pesticide
residue in food is okay.
Uh,
you find that often the government or the,
uh,
the purveyor of the dangerous
technology will make an argument.
Well,
you know what,
uh,
let's,
let's average the risk.
Uh,
so the Nuclear Regulatory Commission
reduced its radiation dose estimate of the
inhabitants by averaging the
exposure to the population.
Uh,
so Rosalee Bartelle from the nuclear
regulatory commission protested to this
arguing.
This is like telling one
smoking member of family,
his or her risk of lung cancer is lowered
if the other nonsmoking members of the
family are included.
And an average risk is given,
it's scientifically ridiculous
as an approach to public health.
So this idea of,
of averaging risk across people when
you have some people that would be more
exposed than others,
uh,
some people would have a diet that
might be high and coconut milk.
Uh,
and during periods of drought throughout
the Marshall Islands in the Pacific,
it's pretty well known that a,
the islanders stayed hydrated by
drinking more and more coconut milk.
Coconut milk happens to be
loaded with saturated fats.
And so how the saturated fats were very
effective and binding on to some of the
radionuclides.
And that explained why the drought was
correlated with an increase in the body
concentration of some of the compounds.
So the idea of averaging that across the
entire population across space and time
made no sense.
By 1999,
the government accounting office
is what it used to be called,
by the way,
that's now the government accountability
office if you ever are searching for
it.
And it's a great site to look at for
critical evaluations of government to
activities and particularly with respect
to environmental and health problems
associated with dangerous technologies.
That's government accountability office.
Uh,
they argued for restricted access and uh,
that,
uh,
if the return or the former residents,
occurred that it would expose them to,
to,
uh,
dangerous levels of radiation despite
the fact that they'd spent $100 million
trying to restore the site.
By 1980,
the Department of Energy,
uh,
concluded that the Bikinians
could return to a new island,
which is one location
and the Bikini Atoll,
uh,
that received the,
the least amount of radiation,
but only if only if they ate no more than
50% of locally grown food and spent no
more than 10% of their
time on Bikini Island.
So this idea that they could adjust
their behavior in a way that would reduce
their exposure is a very interesting one.
One of the islanders.
Uh,
Pero Joel in 1989 reflected on the second,
uh,
exodus from the island,
saying finally the Americans and the
scientists came back a few years later
saying that we had to leave again.
They said we'd ingested too much poison
and that it wasn't safe to live on
bikini anymore.
And we didn't care at this point
because we'd already started to get that
hopeless feeling again though,
because we all wanted to stay on Bikini.
We did explore all possibilities and
an attempt to find a way out of this
problem.
We kept thinking,
the Americans first told us
it was safe to live here.
Then they changed their minds
and some rules for us to follow.
Now they're telling us to
leave and should we go.
So they were constantly,
uh,
being manipulated by a estimates of,
of,
uh,
what was risky and what was safe.
Uh,
and gradually,
uh,
this became the site of extended
epidemiological studies of,
of the,
the health,
uh,
very carefully correlated
with measurements of,
of,
uh,
new Clyde's in their body.
The quality of this science
is really extraordinary.
Uh,
again,
it's exemplary in in the 20th century.
And they found that thyroid disease on
the islands that experienced the greatest
fallout,
uh,
was excessive.
More than a third of all the
residents have thyroid disease.
On,
on Roger Lab,
Ron's lab was an island,
uh,
that following the Bravo test
that a thermonuclear explosion,
the hydrogen bomb.
Uh,
they hadn't expected that the
ash would reach Ron Jalop.
Uh,
but the ash fell out of
the sky like it was snow.
And the children were described
as running along the beach,
picking up the snow and
throwing it over their heads,
uh,
eating it and rubbing it into their skin.
And it didn't take long before they,
uh,
realized that something was terribly awry.
And,
and,
uh,
their skin started to burn,
the,
they became a nausea and vomited
because of their radiation poisoning,
then they lost their hair.
So that,
uh,
the,
the combination of exposure to
strontium that lodges in the bone to,
to,
uh,
the,
iodine one 31 that lodges in the fibroid
eventually led to this fibroid disease.
So what are the remedies?
What are the remedies for
populations such as this?
Uh,
well,
and we'll come back to this,
uh,
when we get back together on Thursday,
but litigation is one,
uh,
litigation is a really,
difficult,
uh,
approach because of the amount
of time it normally takes.
A but also the amount of
funding that it would take,
uh,
in litigation,
that would be,
uh,
brought against the United States
government would be fought intensively.
So that a,
it's not uncommon for
litigation to span of pattern,
a period of time,
including a decade,
a financial compensation,
financial compensation to a,
those that can demonstrate that
they end their property taken away,
that they had their livelihoods
taken away or that they lost their,
their health financial support.
So the building of schools or
hospitals or roadways or ah,
job training or that's another
possible form of support or community
development,
medical monitoring and medical treatment,
and also the landscape land
restoration costs such as,
uh,
those that occurred,
when they removed the soils,
uh,
when they brought in the trees that
cost the government $100 million.
So,
uh,
I'll close with this slide that,
a $20 million resettlement trust fund for
the people of Bikini was authorized by
Congress,
uh,
and it was later supplemented
with an additional $90 million.
And these were used for the
construction and resettlement,
uh,
of the Bikinians to live on Kili
island and another atole a nearby,
uh,
and,
a fiscal year budget now ranges between
about 7 million and $10 million.
It's going into this community,
uh,
that originally was only
several hundred people in size.
So we'll come back to
this a again on Thursday.
And then,
once again,
my apologies for being late today.